throughout the 20th century the average
score on IQ tests across the world grew
significantly does this mean humans are
getting smarter his intelligence going
to keep growing and what will
intelligence mean in the future will
emotional intelligence sharing
understanding of others be considered
more important than abstract logic will
humans be eclipsed by intelligent
machines we are some of the planet's
leading intelligence experts to share
their views during the 20th century IQs
around the world increased 30 points
which is huge the difference between 100
and 130 is the difference between
someone ranked as average and someone
rated as gifted and so what that shows
is clearly intelligence can be increased
academic intelligence or analytical
intelligence can be increased creativity
you learn by having good parenting and
good schooling that encourages you to be
creative in common sense you learn from
the mistakes you and others make in your
life and how to fix them increasing
quality of nutrition better education
and greater exposure to more new
technologies are all factors behind our
increasing intelligence but will we ever
hit a limit because we're gonna keep on
finding problems creating problems that
require new tools we're gonna keep the
that's been going on I don't know if
won't reach the limit of human
intelligence because we don't know what
the limit is the one thing we can be
pretty sure of is that we all could do
much better than we're doing so
regardless of what that limit is people
could be much smarter if they focused on
how can we make the world a better place
we have no idea what the limit of human
intelligence might be I think in society
today we've only scratched the surface
on our intellectual capacity and we will
continue to grow moving forward I'd like
to see us embrace the notion that
intelligence is truly malleable that we
can grow
and develop and get smarter but not all
our experts agree the earliest humans
like us with our brain capacity go back
350,000 years and we know now that those
people involved in long-distance trade
and go back 100,000 years and people
were developing and paint workshops and
a little bit later they're doing plots
with abstract symbols those people with
clearly modern human beings has changed
since then
one issue we're trying to determine
whether intelligence is increasing or
not is how we measure it IQ tests
focused too specifically on abstract
logic to tell us everything we need to
know about a person's intelligence so
maybe we're looking at intelligence the
wrong way perhaps it's time we stop
thinking about intelligence as an
inbuilt quality we each have but it's
something more fluid I would like to see
society place less emphasis on
intelligence this is conventionally
defined because basically it's very much
viewed as individual whereas in fact
most of what we do in the world is in
groups we work in teams we work in
groups we work together mutually to
solve problems I think we need as a
society to put more emphasis on real
world intelligence how do you use
whether it's your IQ or your creative
intelligence how do you use these kinds
of knowledge and skills for a common
good if we start to think of
intelligence as a way of improving the
common good we also need to ensure that
everyone's perspectives are included the
neurodiversity movement which has been
growing exponentially in the last few
years makes the argument that
individuals with different kinds of
neurological capacities should not be
excluded but should be integrated into
society because they have so much more
to benefit that society it was developed
by autistic activists who argued that
autistic people people with intellectual
differences all people had the
to shape and change the world somebody
like Greta thumb burg is a perfect
example of someone who's different style
of thinking has led her to be able to
see the world in a new and radical and
important way it may be that we can all
come together to use all different forms
of intelligence to improve the world but
what about artificial intelligence are
we likely to be out thought outgrown or
even replaced by intelligent machines I
would say that artificial intelligence
and human intelligence really are two
completely separate phenomena I would
say that artificial intelligence really
isn't bound by the limits of human
intelligence for better or worse and so
there may be things that humans remain
better at and things that artificial
intelligence is better at I think one of
the great fallacies is the whole idea of
using computers as analogy to brains oh
wait organic brains are very very
different from computers the kind of
intelligence we have is responsive to
environment in a way that a computer
isn't so I don't think computer
intelligence and human intelligence are
in any way comparable well that's a
relief
so although AI will change so much about
our world it sounds like our old wet
brains won't be eclipsed and while our
experts don't all agree that our species
will keep getting smarter how we use our
intelligence to shape the world we live
in is clearly still in our own hands and
minds